un mot peut-être de la situation sur le
sur le terrain où en est-on exactement
alors à parthout dans le Donbass il y a
deux autres points chauds en ce moment
c'est vous que l'État qui est au
sud-ouest de Donets que la plus grande
ville du dolbase qui contrôlée par les
forces russes depuis 2014 en réalité et
puis dans la région de Luans qui est une
ville déjà
occupée par les forces russes jusqu'à
récemment l'histoire était plutôt les
Ukrainiens qui avançaient petit à petit
vers criminal dans la vue de reprendre
cette ville maintenant visiblement la
direction s'est inversée de la vie des
Ukrainiens de l'aveu des Ukrainiens et
aussi des analyses internationaux c'est
les Russes qui ont maintenant l'avantage
et qui attaque depuis criminat vers le
sud et l'ouest pour les l'état-major
Ukrainiens peut-être que cette offensive
cette grande offensive russe dont on
parle depuis plusieurs semaines a déjà
commencé dans ces deux directions en
tout cas ils disent observer une
intensification de leur tentative de
percer pour le moment ils affirment
avoir résisté à ses tentatives mais
visiblement la situation devient de plus
en plus difficile dans le don de basse
mais il convient tout de même de
rappeler que quelque part les Ukrainiens
estiment que les Russes ne sont pas
vraiment prêts non plus leur force
mobilisée non pas tous compléter leur
formation et si les Russes accélèrent en
ce moment c'est peut-être justement
d'une crainte que les Ukrainiens vont
bientôt recevoir de nouvelles armes de
l'Occident et que maintenant il se
dépêche ce qui peut ne pas être les
Ukrainiens experts la meilleure
stratégie pour les Russes impossible
d’univers de ne pas vous interroger sur
ce déplacement de Wallonie zellinski à
Bruxelles le président ukrainien a
quitté son pays pour la deuxième fois
depuis le début du conflit est-ce que
c'est un moment une séquence déjà qui
est suivie commentée par les
Ukrainiens eux-même et qu'est-ce qu'ils
en attendent
absolument vous savez
Vladimir Zelenski ne fait pas
complètement l'unanimité chez les
Ukrainiens notamment récemment il a été
critiqué par certains pour sa gestion
des affaires de corruption qui ont
émergées il a limogé bouquet de
ministres il y a une confusion
maintenant sur l'avenir du ministre de
la défense alors ce n'est pas comme si
on était encore dans une situation où
tout le monde applaudit pour le diverses
qui dans tout ce qu'il fait mais quand
il va à l'étranger essayer de convaincre
les dirigeants étrangers de fournir plus
d'armes à l'Ukraine plus rapidement il
est vraiment applaudis en Ukraine parce
que les Ukrainiens apprécient la
rhétorique qu'il emploie ses discours
qu'il fait et puis surtout ils sont tous
d'accord sur ce point je pense en
Ukraine il y a vraiment très très peu de
voix qui célébraient pour dire que
peut-être que ce serait mieux de ne pas
recevoir ses armes tout de suite non
tout le monde est d'accord avec le
président et il y a plus ou moins aurait
envie d'employer exactement les mêmes
arguments que lui on les entend c'est
des arguments tout le temps pas le même
ce matin j'ai tourné avec une équipe de
défense antérienne et il disait
exactement la même chose que ce que
voulait dire zelens qui vient de dire ce
matin à Bruxelles à savoir que ce n'est
pas uniquement l'Ukraine que les forces
armées de l'Ukraine défendent
aujourd'hui mais bien l'Europe les
valeurs européennes et le P dans le
monde à long terme merci beaucoup
Gulliver crack vous qui êtes notre
correspondant à Kiev merci les